hey 42 here nature often presents us
with some rather uncanny and
unexplainable events here is some of the
strangest natural occurrences of all
time angel hair is a rare phenomena
where extremely fine silken threads fall
from the sky it has been described as
similar to cobwebs however it is
extremely delicate and appears to
completely vanish when you touch it the
phenomenon has been witnessed most often
in North America Australia New Zealand
and Western Europe there is no known
evidence that tells us where this
strange substance comes from or what is
made up of the materials extreme
sensitivity makes it almost impossible
to collect and analyze many believe it
is linked to UFO sightings as many have
reported seeing angel hair at suspected
UFO crash locations there have also been
reports of angel hair sightings at the
miracle of the Sun in Fatima in June
1908 a ball of fire exploded in a remote
area of Russia it caused localized
earthquakes and instantly flattened 80
million trees over an area of 830 square
miles an explosion of such magnitude
would have been capable of wiping out an
entire city however because the area is
so remote there were no fatalities it is
now known as the Tunguska event because
of its close proximity to the Tunguska
River the blast reached 15 megatons of
energy that's a thousand times more
powerful than the Hiroshima bomb
research suggested the explosion was
caused by an asteroid impact because a
nearby lake is believed to have been
created by the impact however other
researchers say the lake was there
before the event
over a thousand scholarly papers have
been published on the event however we
still don't know for certain what
happens that day if you think fireballs
are weird how about an intelligent ball
of lightning ball lightning as it's
known is a seemingly paranormal
phenomenon where a sphere of lightning
appears and flies around in an
autonomous fashion ball lightning has a
life span of less than five seconds it
can appear randomly at any location
during a thunderstorm
however the creepiest thing about ball
lightning is that it acts as though it
has intelligence of its own it usually
enters buildings through a window or
door it avoids colliding with unit and
navigates itself through hallways also
witnesses say ball lightning can pass
through walls however sometimes it
leaves a hole in the wall and other
times it passes through without leaving
a trace as if it can do what it wants
one of the first documented sightings of
ball lightning was in January 1984
according to eyewitnesses ball lightning
approximately four inches in diameter
entered a Russian passenger aircraft
flew above the heads of the startled
passengers then once it reached the tail
section split into two glowing crescents
then join together again and exited the
plane it left two holes in the walls of
the plane because this natural phenomena
is so rare there is currently no
generally accepted theory for ball
lightning and it has baffled scientists
for centuries in 2000 in Ethiopia fish
fell from the sky yes that's right a
local newspaper report
the unusual rain of fish which dropped
in millions from the air son dead and
offers still struggling creative panic
amongst the mostly religious farmers but
this is not the only account of raining
animals far from it
in fact almost every year since records
began there have been reports all around
the world of animals miraculously
raining down from the sky in some cases
hundreds of miles from the nearest body
of water but it's not just fish people
have also reported raining frogs snakes
and even alligators science a is the
most likely explanation for this
phenomena is a type of tornado called a
waterspout which forms above water a
waterspout has enough sucking power to
suck up masses of water as well as any
animals
it contains once the animals have been
sucked into the upper atmosphere they
can be carried by winds hundreds of
miles until they eventually fall back to
earth as rain in the summer of 1997 an
ultra-low frequency sound was detected
underwater by the US National Oceanic
and Atmospheric Administration it
sounded like this the sound was
affectionately named the bloop the bloop
was so loud it was picked up on multiple
sensors over 5,000 kilometers apart
according to scientists who studied the
bloop it matches the audio profile of a
living creature however there is no
known animal that could have produced a
sound of such amplitude if it did come
from an animal
it would have to be several times the
size of a blue whale which led to
speculations all over the Internet of a
giant underwater sea monster
however after many years of scientists
being baffled by the bloop NOAA recently
discovered the noise was caused by a
nice quake in Antarctica which is when
an ice shelf cracks an estimated two to
ten percent of the world's population
are plagued by a relentless mysterious
humming sound of unknown origin this
unexplainable phenomena is known as the
hot scientists have investigated the
home multiple times however in places
where the home has reportedly been heard
scientists could never locate the source
of the sound which makes investigating
this peculiar phenomenon rather
difficult
according to sufferers of the home it
sounds similar to a diesel engine truck
idling outside their house but what's
even weirder about this strange sound is
that it isn't present everywhere it can
only be heard in certain places notable
places the home has been heard include
Taos New Mexico Bristol England and logs
in Scotland but the home is constantly
appearing in new towns and cities across
the world it has become such a global
problem that a website was started that
keeps track of every location the home
has been heard around the world perhaps
one of the weirdest natural phenomena of
all time our rods rods were discovered
accidentally in March of 1994 by
filmmaker Jose s kamila rods are
peculiar flying entities that can only
be seen on slowed-down videotape and
sometimes in still photographs rods are
cylindrical shaped objects that travel
too fast to be seen by the naked eye and
move through the air like a fish moves
through the sea because of the speed
they travel they
have never been studied by science but
there are many theories as to what rods
really are some believe they are secret
hi-tech missiles being tested by the
government because they appear to travel
in an absolute straight line others
theorized that they are entities from
another dimension briefly passing
through our dimension in a split second
or they could simply be another species
of insect still unknown to science
thanks for the view subscribe for more
for TTIP